be bright don't look for the light
become it also how I Drive my car
hi fine a miss grace Alma give you did
not know now you know your life is
different now I'm breath from trying to
be charming Spring Break is something
that happens in the world to people
Spring Break right folks a certain
emotion either oh I have honestly never
had a wild Cancun ask Spring Break
I haven't does the girl wearing a be
bright sweatshirt next to a gif
overcompensating artificial flower but I
watch enough movies television shows and
MTV summer beach house to throw back in
all the kind of cliches that make up a
solid Spring Break and after careful
evaluation I learned you don't need to
go all the way to Mexico to have the
most cliche Spring Break you can have
the most stereotypical Spring Break in
the comfort of your own home I'm happy
about that too that your imagination
free and trailer cameras on there's how
you do Spring Break at home
congratulations your memory foam that
was what that was dry great yes
wow that's a wide variety of oils I know
where's my phone oh wow check out your
life wow I did not expect that where is
she Oh
what car did you get teabags oh that's
disappointing there you go there's how
you can have Spring Break at home and
here's a bonus let's stand in your
butthole that's a difficult scenario to
resolve thank you guys so much for
watching I hope that you liked this
video if you did not enjoy it please
give it a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe by clicking this button right
here Wow so that you're always alerted
when I make videos that you probably
will find negative emotions to attach to
it with I don't know